Before PHRs and sites like Patients
Like Me, hospitals and physicians
were able to establish portals,
essentially web pages where their
patients could do some of the things we
discussed under personal health records.
The first of these is now
part of Relay Health,
itself a part of McKesson Technology
Solutions For Healthcare.
Here patients can get test results,
they can request or
sometimes even make appointments,
and they can pay their provider,
something you don't see on PHR sites,
which emphasizes the key difference.
Portals are generally
provided to the patient,
while PHRs are generally
patient initiated and operated.
Importantly as you can see here,
patients can now Download their
Health Data, in this case using
Blue Button Plus, a technology we've not
previously mentioned,
that is intended for just this purpose.
And one that is getting a lot
of attention because of the VDT
requirements of Meaningful Use 2.